welcome to thick boy fight news let's
dive in last saturday during ufc long
island the ufc made the major
announcement that charles oliveira and
islam makachev will battle for the
lightweight title at ufc 280 in abu
dhabi the highly anticipated bout will
feature two of the organization's best
grapplers oliveira told suredog.com that
he doesn't feel like islam has the upper
hand on the ground despite being coached
by lightweight legend khabib
nurmagomedov i'm better than him
standing up and also on the ground he
said he would beat me on the ground if
he wants we can start the fight from the
guard position he can start from the top
i'm the guy who has the most submissions
in ufc history i have the submissions
and bonus record i'm not there to play
they must be careful about what they are
saying because i am the biggest problem
of that division i have three months in
camp and i'll be more than ready to show
him what i'm capable of
oliveira told suredog.com that despite
heading to makachev's part of the world
he isn't worried about giving up home
field advantage
they talked a lot of [ __ ] to the media
that they would go to brazil to beat me
up in front of my fans they had the
opportunity to agree to that since i
tried hard to make that fight at home
but they never accepted we even tried to
make it in a neutral territory but what
ended up happening the champion will
fight on the opponent's home soil for
the third consecutive time but as i
proved with dustin and justin that's not
a problem when the cage closes it's just
me and my opponent i'm going to abu
dhabi to shut islam and khabib's mouth
in their home
ufc 280 is shaping up to be a mega card
in addition to the lightweight
championship 280 will feature pyotr yawn
rashan o'malley bella muhammad vs sean
brady reportedly aljamain sterling vs tj
dillashaw and now according to espn
banil daryush will face mateusz gamrat
on the card deryush who had to withdraw
from a title eliminator fight with
makachev in february sees this as his
next fight before challenging for the
belt telling espn winner fights for the
belt i'm definitely happy with the
matchup i just want to fight the best
staying in the lightweight division tmz
sports caught up with michael chandler
to talk about a potential matchup
against conor mcgregor since joining the
ufc in 2021 michael chandler has become
one of the organization's most exciting
fighters with a fight of the year
performance against justin gaichi at ufc
268 and a knockout of the year contender
after his vicious front kick ko of tony
ferguson in may it's with good reason
chandler believes a bout between him and
mcgregor would be the best business for
the ufc if conor's coming back anytime
soon i think me and conor would make
some fireworks and it's a fight the fans
want to see i think it's the biggest
fight we can make in mixed martial arts
right now and i try to say that as
humble as possible but i think it's a
huge fight do you agree with michael
chandler let us know what you think of
chandler verse mcgregor in the comments
at the one championship amazon prime
press conference on wednesday night in
los angeles grappling specialist
danielle kelly took a shot at current
adam weight champion angela lee when
asked whether a grappling match with lee
was an option kelly responded
i wouldn't be opposed to it but i'm a
jujitsu person so i've been focused on
legit grapplers but if they want to give
me that match i'll take it in a
heartbeat lee wasn't granted an
opportunity to respond during the press
conference but thursday morning the
thick boy fight news team caught up with
her to hear her reaction on kelly's
comments and a potential shot at champ
champ status
honestly man this whole thing about
kelly and how she was at the press con
seen her over the past few days
she's just like a little bit so into
herself right and
i don't got time for that honestly like
i'm focused on the big fights right now
my title defense or moving up in weight
capturing that second belt and so
i think she's just trying to drag me and
pull me in and
get herself a big fight so i'm just
gonna
tune her out angela lee also told thick
boy fight news how being a new mother
has changed her motivation while
fighting
it's hard to explain but once you become
a mom
your whole purpose shifts and it's a
whole new motivation for doing things um
and
yeah i mean my daughter she's my pride
and joy and uh
i love what i do and i love that i'm
able to take her with me on this journey
thick boy fight news also spoke with
hall of famer and current vice president
of one championship rich franklin about
the streaming deal with prime video when
asked about the challenges and
opportunities the organization will face
breaking into north america rich was
confident the quality of product they
are offering will break through in this
competitive sports landscape you know i
think i think the biggest challenge
coming to the us is the fact that the
sports market here is so mature
so breaking through all the white noise
i i think the thing i'm most excited
about is the fact that one championship
unlike every other mma organization on
the planet we're not an mma organization
we're a martial arts organization so we
have
amazing kickboxing fights muay thai
fights grappling matches and you know
for example if you've seen our muay thai
matches these are done in the four ounce
gloves and it's
truly like some explosive stuff that'll
keep you on the edge of your seat i
think that when we deliver our product
that mixture of the all these different
disciplines along with the entertainment
value of the product that it's going to
be something that the american fans have
just not seen
ufc welterweight gilbert burns tweeted
that he will be prepared if one of nate
diaz or hamza chemayev has to withdraw
at ufc 279. welterweight bala muhammad
also sent out several tweets in support
of nate diaz after the bat with shimaya
was announced first tweeting let's go
nate
209 later responding to a fan suggesting
muhammad helps train diaz he tweeted hit
my line at nate diaz 209 we'll all
finish his string of tweets by mapping
his dream scenario for the welterweight
division i hope nate and leon both win
and ruin everyone's plans leon edwards
will challenge kamara usman for the
welterweight title at ufc 278.
looking for more original mma content
check out the rest of thick boy youtube
exclusive interviews opinion and fight
analysis is available weekly on the shob
show food truck diaries and fight night
flashbacks subscribe so you don't miss
any of the action
[Music]
you